[Music]
it's the invisible pollution that you
can't see that's really harmful
[Music]
what do you think of climate change i
think
they will have to hire an army
because it's everywhere
charlie delta crossing runway 1-6-3-4
you've only seen the head of a pen
of what's out here
[Music]
we're on the road in texas to find a gas
that's warming our planet more quickly
than any other it's invisible it's
odorless and here in the vastness of the
permian basin we're told it's everywhere
look how big that player is
we're following sharon wilson and her
team from earthworks clean air advocates
who for nearly a decade have been trying
to expose this hidden polluter methane
we pull up alongside one of the
thousands of oil facilities which dot
this landscape
and with a specialist camera sharon
shows us the problem
i'm going to
put it in high sensitivity mode
and if you want to just look
wow so you can't see anything
when you're looking with the naked eye
but as soon as you look through here
you can see you could see quite clearly
that there is vapor coming out of these
tanks
methane is a byproduct of oil extraction
and from the tanks holding the crude it
is seeping out it causes pressure
so they can't leave
the pressure in the tank
so they have to either route it
somewhere
through a vapor recovery device
or they have to release it to the
atmosphere
the operators are allowed to emit
certain quantities of methane but checks
on what's actually happening are lacks
and so it is the imagery from spot
checks like this which sharon has taken
to glasgow to focus mines
the team are not popular here staff from
the plant watch us and then call the
police accusing us of trespassing if
everything checks out fine
i mean i'll be i'll be out of here
the officer agreed that we were not
we're never going to do that at another
site an unlit flare stack and through
sharon's camera the consequence is
exposed the flares are used to burn off
the gas so often though they are
partially lit or not a light at all and
so it's released into the air and you
can't see it why haven't they lit it
i guess they don't have to
who's going to make them light it i've
been reporting it to the state every
time
i guess nobody makes them
at a third site more emissions from a
flare stack sharon's research with
others has concluded that 10 of flares
are not lit or are partially lit they
say this means companies here are
emitting up to three and a half times
more methane than was feared and here a
leak too
we approached the companies who operate
these plants only one responded saying
that they had found a leak on a tank
that they'd sold recently to another
operator
all this is a huge problem because the
scientists say that over a 20-year
period methane is 80 times more potent
at warming than co2
in short then it is a very very
significant contributor to our warming
planet and the hope from those who are
exposing the emissions is that they can
show us all the scale and the impact
good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the permian basin
international oil show this is but up
the road in the local town a trade fair
hints at just how vital the oil industry
is to this community this is where the
biden administration's pledges to save
the planet are up against local politics
jobs and people
what is regulations going to do
i mean how do you regulate the climate
it changed in the dark ages it's changed
throughout history
every business in this area whether it's
directly related to the oil field or not
is going to be
severely impacted if they shut any of it
down i think there's a lot of regular
regulatory things that they put out
there but nobody really super adheres to
what do you think of climate change
i think it's [ __ ]
that's it
to runway 2-0 via alpha
beyond those hardened opinions it is the
scale of all this that's overwhelming
the permian basin covers more than 80
thousand square miles of texas and new
mexico
with a specialist camera mounted on the
wing a crew of two working for a company
called kairos aerospace can now cover
vast areas of land
each patch below us is an oil facility
and wherever there is oil there is the
potential for methane to be emitted we
fly in a grid pattern images from the
camera are processed and the results are
striking
karos's clients are the oil companies
themselves the data that's collected on
this plane is passed to those oil
companies to help them stop the
emissions
reducing methane emissions is a key
component of america's pledges in
glasgow sharon has taken her research to
scotland but she is not optimistic
the biden administration listens to the
industry more than he listens to the
people and he wants to be seen as this
compromiser
this big negotiator
but we're past all of that we're past
compromising we need a really strong
leader who will who will make the united
states
lead the way
and that's not happening
it is so often the determination of just
a few to expose the damage done by so
many but this is a toxic political
climate exposure is one thing change is
quite another mark stone sky news in the
oil fields of texas
you